that man is not mentally fit to be
president and the people around him
covering all of this up they are the
worst type of enablers because they're
putting the country at greater risk even
the world at a greater risk here with
reaction author of here's the deal
kellyanne Conway number one New York
Times bestseller and Fox News
contributor Joe Concha kellyanne look I
pointed it out during the campaign I got
criticized
um I don't think there's anybody that
has any ounce of intellectual honesty
can argue with the fact that he's just
not up for the job it's that simple well
Democrats take the Bold step and tell
them that
while they fear that then the next
person in line for the job isn't up for
the job either her name's Kamala Harris
and she doesn't do much better at the
talking thing let me let me vote on that
I agree she's not up for the job either
strongly so she's not and so there is
that fear by the way you know Sean and
Joe it's so fascinating isn't it that
when the Democrats now are coming out of
the woodwork and saying somehow a guy
who wasn't too old 18 months ago is too
old now and in firm uh they they stop
short of saying get rid of him now just
don't run again in 2024 because they
don't say let's just get Kama to step in
there she neither like him she also does
not Inspire confidence or demonstrate
competence look this is binary under
Donald Trump record low poverty under
Joe Biden record low approval ratings
under Donald Trump we had the highest
unemployment in 50 years under Joe Biden
highest inflation of 40 years why is
this important well it's important
because those weren't just about those
individual personalities or even
presidents it was about policies and I
think we're all being seduced into
talking too much about Joe Biden as fun
as it is
I think we should be talking about the
Democrat Sean the difference between 15
seats for the Republicans this fall and
50 in the house could be the ability to
make all of the Democrats not just Joe
Biden own and eat all these terrible
policies you have these moderate
Democrats now like Alyssa salt came from
Michigan today pretending that she was
she was worried about inflation she was
warning the Biden White House oh no what
can we do it reminds me of the
democratic moderates who were upset
after the 2020 election saying don't you
ever again out of those three words
defund the police I almost lost my seat
now they're saying about inflation these
are democratic policy problems not just
Biden problems I want them all gone
you know I I look at this Joe Concha and
now we're seeing the media two and a
half years later acknowledge the obvious
that we had now there's two points about
this one any Democrat that might replace
Biden is probably going to adopt the
same policies and similarly be beholden
to the climate alarmist cult that is the
Democratic Socialist Party so things
won't change in that respect but what
about the people I mean to be honest
they all know how bad his condition is
and it's probably worse than we even can
see you know is do we not get to the
point where it's borderline elder abuse
with this guy forcing him out there and
he comes stumbling stammering you know
tripping and falling and the wind blew
him over at some point does anybody care
about him enough to say Joe I think it's
time you need to hand the reins off to
Kamala or somebody else
one would hope so Sean but but I think
again when we focus on age the premise
seems to be that well when Joe Biden had
his fastball he had the proper instincts
and had the proper perspective and
policies to move the country forward and
you ask Robert Gates for example who was
his defense secretary under Obama Biden
and said and this is what Gates said in
his book in 2014 that he was wrong about
every foreign policy decision throughout
his 50-year career whether it be in the
senate or as vice president remember
this is the guy who told Barack Obama he
should not go into Pakistan and get uh
Osama Bin Laden this is the guy who
voted against the first Gulf War that
even Al Gore had had supported at that
point so you know his instincts on
foreign policy have been horrible and
then when his Instinct now or at least
the instincts of his handlers is let's
spend trillions more so we could lower
inflation you know that's not the way it
works but then to the age thing I mean
when he gets up in front of the Press on
an international stage and again does
that whole they gave me a list of
reporters to call on thing he's done
this multiple times as president it's
several flavors is stupid and it's like
the porch light is on in no one's home
you would think someone sane and sober
in the white house will pull them aside
and say please stop sharing that
information because it may look like
you're avoiding hard questions and
calling it on those who only ask those
of the cotton candy variety Barack Obama
was able to win re-election yeah I know
and Obama he won re-election but not
because his policies and performance you
know we're all that great right but
because he could put together a good
speech and give coherent answers unlike
his former vice president is now doing
as president but one more one more point
kellyanne's exactly right you connect
every Democrat that is running in the
Congress in the senate for a seat or
running for reelection to Joe Biden on
inflation on education on gas prices and
on crime and if you do that and you
focus on those four issues like a laser
I don't see how too many of them will
lose because Democrats don't have a
bumper sticker and they know it Sean
quick exit question and prediction from
both of you kellyanne will Joe Biden
finish his first term
yes he's not going to finish any
sentences but he will finish his first
term that's too funny I cannot laugh uh
Joe Concha
it's like trying to take the keys from
your grandfather who's 84 and shouldn't
be driving anymore he's not letting go
of those keys Joe Biden's not letting go
of his presidency
I take the keys and I'd find a way and I
I'd hire a driver get him an Uber
account whatever I needed to do
kellyanne Conway thank you Joe Contra
thank you thank you I appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else